the celebrities Matthew McConaughey who
I actually generally liked but he's
wrong about this too he doesn't want us
to talk about the killings in Chicago or
Atlanta or New York crime rates spiking
going through the roof 40 million people
being thrown out of jobs tearing down
our history tearing down our monuments
hating our own country becoming the
laughingstock of the world you know want
to talk about any of that he just wants
you to wear your damn mask happy 240 4th
birthday America ho wait we just going
through some growing pains and this one
not me
yes sir yes ma'am it is hotter and more
ways than one but growing pains are a
good thing because how the hell else
were we gonna grow up I think we gotta
look each other in the eye I think we
got to look ourselves in the eye we
gotta look in the mirror and ask our
still attack and I'd be better I can I
expect more of myself than others how
can I be more responsible how can I have
more compassion I gotta have more
courage how can I be more fair how do I
make sure I wear the damn mask we
individually make these changes that's
how we make a collective change I love
Matthew McConaughey cause he's a weird
guy he comes off kind of weird and
usually as though he's just had a couple
puffs on that old Peruvian parsley every
so often but that line that drives me
crazy is where the damn mask right
because wear the damn mask is not saying
I need to change something about myself
maybe he's trying to phrase the sentence
that way but the the sentiment of where
the damn mask is to you it's to shame
everybody else for not wearing the mask
the mask which by the way we were all
told for weeks don't wear it's not
effective it's not good to wear a mask
you can then look at some of the science
that the CDC has posted some of the
papers there is very little evidence
that the cloth masks do anything much
less your bandana that you think is
going to save you from the virus very
little scientific evidence that this
mitigates the virus at all in fact I
would I would bet if you're one of the
people who thinks that the mask is the
most important thing we can do to fix
our country right now you are basing
that not on some scientific study not
even on historical
of common sense you're basing it on some
like stupid meme that you saw on Twitter
that shows or some meme that you show on
CNN that shows that you know air doesn't
go through masks air goes through cloth
I assure you I promise you it does that
that is not the biggest issue where the
masks don't wear the mask you know it
doesn't really bother me what you do
either way but this idea that that the
mask is the most important thing is an
attempt to distract you from a swindle
that is going on they have shut down our
country they've shut down much of our
political process we are in a
presidential election year we're not
allowed to have a campaign Joe Biden has
told us he's not going to campaign he's
gonna use that to try to get out of the
debates they're trying to shut down
Trump rallies they're trying to shut
down your ability to vote anyone noticed
that they're trying to pass this the
this massive mail-in ballot legislation
throughout many states meaning that
everybody goes and gets about a ballot
even if you do show up to the polling
station there will still be all of these
mail-in ballots out there which can be
harvested in some states legally in
California now it says what party you're
in on the outside of the envelope wonder
what's going to happen to the Republican
envelopes to say nothing of the killing
in the mayhem going on all around the
country and they have actually managed
to convince you these con artists these
frauds have convinced you that the most
important thing is to get some suburban
housewife to put a bandanna around her
face are you kidding me and we're
falling for it
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description